best known for his role as sadistic boy
King Joffrey Baratheon in Game of
Thrones
Irish actor Jack Gleeson seemed poised
for big things but for a while he was
pretty much nowhere to be found
so what exactly happened to him here is
an important thing to know Gleeson
really isn't interested in living an
actor's lifestyle in an interview with
the Irish Independent Gleeson said when
I started doing Game of Thrones
perhaps the reality was made too real
for me the lifestyle that comes with
being an actor in a successful TV show
isn't something I gravitate towards in
fact he only started acting because it
was just something for him to do Gleeson
started taking acting classes with his
two older sisters at his local community
center because there wasn't much else
available
he told vulture it was nearby I did it
because it looked fun if the community
center hosted karate classes instead I
might be a karate person but for some
reason they happen to have acting
classes so I went to them perhaps the
main reason Gleeson didn't much like
playing Joffrey was that he just didn't
enjoy working on set you called
specifically Gleeson isn't intrigued by
the faker aspects of filming in an
effects-heavy show like Game of Thrones
he explained to vulture
when you go on to a set you realize the
very visceral reality that you see on
the TV show is a product of a huge
amount of processing and editing and
storytelling that is not present at all
on the day of the filming worse yet
Gleeson found actually doing his job to
be almost entirely unfulfilled and
incredibly boring he said you go and put
your makeup on but your costume on wait
in your Caravan trailer thing for an
hour and then you go to the set and you
film for three minutes and then they
change around the lights and the camera
angle and you wait for an hour and then
you film for another three minutes it's
a very boring tedious process Gleason
was so not into it
in fact that his favorite moment of
filming actually came when he played
dead during Joffrey's funeral simply
because he got to sleep all day he joked
that was a fun experience Gleason
doesn't have any special attachments to
the show which made him famous either in
fact he couldn't care less about the
show or the novels
which it was based of which he only made
it through one before realizing he
didn't have the attention span required
to continue and as for the TV series
Gleason explained there's too much to
catch up on I've not a clue what's going
on in my mind all these characters are
still alive and everyone's in this place
and those people are in that place and
they have these motivations and now
everything's screwed around so much that
it's a completely different show I have
no idea Gleason's not bluffing either he
really doesn't have a clue since he only
ever read his own scenes from the script
he told vulture I'm just selfish maybe I
should get into it I hear it's good
while his stint on Game of Thrones might
have landed Gleeson with a whole heap of
Fame and money he has admitted that he
doesn't really care for either the
former actor claims to live as normal a
life as possible residing alone in a
London flat he describes as nothing out
of the ordinary
even today he'd rather keep it simple
and go about his business then focus on
remaining a celebrity Gleason explains
it's maybe the status thing that I find
uncomfortable people can be wealthy and
not be mean but the status thing some
people when they become famous they feel
better they feel more worthy that's what
makes me really uncomfortable I tried to
eschew as much of that as possible still
Gleason is always happy to snap some
photos with fans retweet jokes about
Joffrey and attend the occasional
convention and as for the money
well it's no secret that Game of Thrones
actors make Bank Gleason included but
the young Irishman doesn't really care
for Gleason money truly isn't everything
he told the Irish independent I'm happy
to sacrifice a big paycheck for my
happiness if that's not too corny a
thing to say it's probably more naive
than mature to say that maybe but that's
how I feel even though Gleason seems
pretty disinterested with on-screen
acting
you'll still be seeing him on TV in the
near future just maybe not where you
might expect coming off his Broadway
puppet show bears in space Gleason saw
himself fitting in nicely on another
popular children themed but adult
oriented television programme explaining
to vulture my dream is getting into some
Adult Swim style things short little
bursts of wackiness maybe a multimedia
thing with puppets and animation and
live-action in 2016 the
also told the herald-sun I wanted to be
a big famous successful actor I suppose
something just changed I still love
acting and I see myself acting in the
future but that kind of spark is not
there anymore but it looks like that
spark has returned in early 2020 Gleason
came out of retirement to be cast in out
of her mind
a BBC two series by comedian Sara Pascoe
that promises to include cast bizarre
characters as well as those unusual
animations that Gleason was looking to
be a part of check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite actors are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you